the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode
good morning everybody uh welcome to
today's presentation my name is michael
baltos
and today i'll be talking about new
advances in order flow analysis and so
it's uh it's 10 o'clock
central time here in chicago i'll get
started in
just about a few seconds here just
waiting for a few uh
last minute attendees to come on but you
know it's been an interesting market uh
you know honestly when um you know if
you asked me last year
what i thought the markets would be like
when if biden wins the the presidency
i thought they'd be a bit calmer but you
know i've been proven wrong
and you know these markets have been
great trading
uh opportunities so and
you know if you're using order flow you
know you can see things that other
traders aren't going to see
all right so what i'll be talking about
today
you know if you can't see my screen or
you can't hear me just let me know
honestly sometimes
it's something as simple as logging out
and logging back in
if you if sound drops off but you know
we did a
technical check this morning and
everything works fine
so in today's presentation you know
there's there's
i'm an overflow guy right i'm a futures
guy you know i trade futures i've been
in the futures industry for
basically my entire career since the 90s
right i started on the cme floor
and i want to share with you what i've
learned
about trading you know it's been
culminated you know over 20 years
of my experience 25 years of my
experience into
you know the last few years when i've
been working with individual traders
retail traders
and developing trading software so
my goal for you today is show you how to
leverage the information that's
generated by the market
so you're always trading in the same
direction as the market right
that's what you want to be doing right
you don't want to always be fighting the
market you know
it's you're going to find yourself
fighting the market you'll be fighting
yourself a lot of times and
ultimately you're going to lose and in
this training you'll discover an easy
way to learn what's working
now for order flow traders you know
there's been big advancements
in the field of order flow analysis
you know just in the last five years
right compared to how it was
10 years ago you're going to see new
ways of viewing market generated
information
and you're going to discover easy to see
order flow trade
setups that you can take advantage of
okay
and what makes order flow different is
you know people think it's uh you know
it overflows a fad
and you know it'll it'll you know it's
just you know it's a buzzword you know
that
for people to get you to part you from
their money
and teach you some trading things it's
not you know orderful has
been around for in some form you know
for well over 100 years you know since
the days of you know jesse livermore
on you know in the 1920s right he wrote
the the one of the great books on
trading not just order flow but trading
in general reminiscence of a stock
operator
he was basically a tape reader which is
someone who reads the order flow
okay and this training is for serious
traders that want to understand what's
actually happening in the market
you know honestly if you're if you're
here you're just looking for some red
light green light system
mike just tell me where to buy should
tell me where to sell that's all i'm
interested in
you know this session is probably not
for you this session is for people that
want to
understand what's actually happening in
the market so they can trade that's what
being a trader is
it's understanding the different pieces
of market information
and putting it together and trading
now if you stick around to the end i'm
going to show you how to get a copy of
my book trading order flow right i've
i wrote this book after i left the
corporate traded world after i left jp
morgan
and you know originally this was i
thought you know i want to write this
book this is going to be my contribution
to the trading society
to the trading world i didn't imagine
that i would get into
developing software but you know this
what you're going to learn in this book
it's 150 pages
is you know very valuable information
that
you're not going to find anywhere else
you know unless someone copied it from
my book
so what makes order flow analysis so
powerful is it gets you as close to the
market
as possible right as close to what's
happening
right now trading in the market as
possible and that's really where you
want to be you know
when there was open outcry you know the
pits trading
you know people paid a lot of money you
know locals
to be down there in the middle of the
order flow to trade it so
you know order flow is very valuable
information because it's going to allow
you to gauge the tendency
that a market will continue in a
direction or stop
you know new trading activity which is
basically volume is what's going to keep
the markets moving in a direction
and by having order flow information you
know it's going to give you
a better picture of what's happening in
the market more so than
what other people out there are looking
at most people are just looking at the
open hi-lo close
and you know maybe volume some of the
time
so you can be able to see things that
other traders are just not paying
attention to
so just really briefly um you know why
you should listen to me you know
everyone says well why should i listen
to you
or you know this person is my name is
michael baltos
all right and i've got over 25 years
professional trading experience i
started on the cme floor
as a runner right the lowest level you
can get started in
um in the in the trading world in those
days was being a runner on the cme floor
that's how i got my foot in the door now
you don't have those opportunities
because there is no trading floor
if you want to become a trader either
one you got to put up your own money
or two you got to go to some you know
fancy school
and get a degree in programming you know
all these jobs i see nowadays for
you know traders and and trading
associates and whatever at these trading
desks
oh you got to be able to program in c
plus plus python you know
sql everything and you know most people
they don't have that you know back in
the old days you could
literally come from any background and
get a job on the trading floor and learn
how to trade so you know
the dynamics of learning how to trade
have have really changed you know
getting a job in the trading industry
has has really changed
so i started on the cme floor with dean
witter back in the early 90s
and eventually you know i worked my way
up you know on the floor eventually i
left the floor when electronic trading
started taking off and i i went
to the upstairs you know they called the
upstairs trading desk
at dean witter to work the
overnight session you know the europeans
the asian session european session and
trade
electronically right trade on globex
trade on project day trade on nymex
access systems as well as all the
markets around the world
i did that for about three years three
or four three and a half years
then i left and i joined edf man in
chicago on their
global macro futures trading desk i
spent two years there then
joined commerce bank in chicago i was a
licensed eurex trader so i traded
obviously all the year x buns bobble
shots dax
euro stocks against the us products and
i spent about three years there after
september 11th
you know i decided i needed some time
off i took about six months off
traveled a bit and you know i was
bouncing around and then
i joined cargill in chicago cargill is
the big commodity trading company
they you know account for about 30 of
the us grain exports 25 of meat exports
you know they're in every commodity you
can imagine also in shipping and in
you know everything in the whole supply
chain you know i've learned
a different facet of the business
besides just futures trading you know i
understood better
um you know the cash market
relationships that
you know the spine demand relationships
that really drive the markets
okay cargill sent me out to singapore to
set up a trading desk when the exchange
closed there
the cymex closed the floor the exchange
didn't close
the floor closed sgx went fully
electronic
so they wanted me to set up a desk there
trading desk
so i did that and then after that i
joined
jp morgan i spent eight years at jp
morgan in singapore as
vice president of futures trading okay
and this was you know it's not some
seconded away in some corner office you
know come in
at nine checking my emails no i'd be
coming in at
5 45 in the morning to trade the globex
open the cme open at 6 00 a.m
singapore time which was 5 p.m chicago
time
until you know until about 5 in the
afternoon
there uh you know when when europe was
open and the european
traders could take over our book but you
know what i was burnt out i
i was in my early 40s and
you know i got married we had a daughter
and i said you know what there's more to
life than
being in an office all day you know and
i said you know i know how to trade i
could do this for myself
and i left jp morgan and i started
trading um you know for myself based on
you know what i knew
you know i'm like you know i'm not
stupid i've been in the industry for
20 plus years you know i know how to
trade
well instead of killing myself making
money for the bank i
i could do this for myself so in 2015
i released the order flows trader
software now i left jp morgan 2013
and you know i just needed some time off
to recharge i started writing my book
and trading for myself but i realized
the order flow software out there
was okay it was basic you know this was
again 2013
you know fast forward now we're 20 21
it's um
you know is that seven eight years
and the software that was out there it
was just basic order flow software
right it would show you the volume trade
on the bid the volume trade on the offer
which is good for
some people but you know
me you know i am like you know i know
computers can do more right i want the
computer to do some of the analysis for
me
so in 2015 or so 2014 i started working
with a programmer saying hey you know
what this is what i look at in the order
flow
put it into the software so that i could
analyze
um what's going on in the market okay
and
2015 is when we released the first
version of order flows trader because
you know people are asking me hey you
know what charts are you looking at you
know
can i get a copy of your software so it
didn't start out that way
whereas like oh you know what i'm going
to become a develop software for traders
it blossom out of me first writing a
book then
me looking at my software saying you
know what this is not good enough
now my software runs on ninjatrader 8
and you know people say is it available
for this platform that platform this
platform that platform no it's on
ninjatrader eight because that's what i
use right
listen i i know a decent amount of stuff
about computers
but i don't know how to do all the
programming and all the stuff that goes
on under the hood
you know i just like to get in the car
and drive right and ninjatrader allows
me to do that i have a programmer who's
excellent does a great job knows exactly
what i like in terms of programming you
know i've been working with him
for six years and right now it's just
for ninja traders not on any other
platform
but if you trade futures you should
really look at the ninjatrader platform
and now it's the order flow footprint
chart with 17 pre-programmed order flow
analysis tools
now the reason i talk about this is
because you know the charts that i'm
using in this presentation are generated
from
the order flows trader software okay
so there's two ways to do things you can
do it the easy way or the hard way i
prefer the easy way the path of least
resistance i want to let the computer
show me what's happening in the market
you know when you're trading for
yourself and you're trying to trade
multiple markets because sometimes you
have to trade multiple markets because
the your primary market can be dead
right it could hardly
be moving and another market is rocking
and rolling and
you feel left you know i hate say feel
left out but
you know you like gosh you know if i
just expand my horizon a little bit
i can take advantage of more
opportunities and that's why having
software that's going to help you with
the analysis
is going to put you ahead of everybody
else you're competing with
right there's you're basically competing
with yourself right that's your own
confidence and discipline as an
individual trader then again you're
trading against everybody else out there
you're trying to get their money put it
in your pocket
so like i said the charts and tools used
in this training are generated from my
software
but what i'm showing you can be used
with other order flow footprint charts
if you know what to look for and you
know how to set it up
right you can set it up in sierra charts
you can set it up in motive wave
and various other softwares
but hopefully you can see how easily and
quickly you can apply order flow
analysis to your trading now before i
jump in
you know just remember trading involves
risk right nothing is risk-free
you know stocks don't always go up
that's you know sorry stonks don't
always go up
um you know bitcoin doesn't always go up
right
you know the market goes up and down and
you gotta realize there's risk involved
in trading you shouldn't trade with
money you can't afford to lose
so have you ever stopped and thought
about where does the information
on the chart comes from right it comes
from the trading data what's actually
being traded
in the market you know charts like this
you know they're easy to read you throw
a 200 day moving average
you know a view app you know but have
you ever start
stopped and thought you know why does
the market stop at this particular level
right a lot of times people like to look
at a chart
after the fact and then reverse engineer
why the move happened
right there's a lot of monday morning
quarterbacking going on
in the markets people say well yeah i
see the market
uh you know it sold off and it started
to rally because of this you know we hit
this level
well you know as a trader you're not
trading
in the past tense you're trading right
now right and that's
where order flow is going to help you is
because you're making trading
decisions right now you know you're not
sitting at the chart after the market's
closed
and saying oh yeah you know i i could
have bought uh
down here and sold up here and then
bought again down here
when it's down here you got to be making
decision do i buy or sell
are we going to bounce up or are we
going to continue to go lower right
that's what traders are constantly faced
with is are these decisions
and that's where having order flow
having market generated data
is going to help you so you know a chart
comes from
charts formed by the time and sales
and it gives you a lot of information
people don't realize you know sometimes
people don't understand
really what they're looking at in the
time and sales and you see there's
oftentimes
there's different colors in the time and
sales you know in this case it's orange
and green well i know that
if it's a particular color i know
whether it's trading on the bid or on
the offer so if it's red i know see
people are selling into this bid
if it's green i know people are buying
this offer so i know
this area here that's all orange is
people selling
right i know it's trading at uh 86 and a
quarter
okay but what kind of trading well it's
selling that's going on
then it's trading 86 and a half okay
well are people buying the sixes and
halves or are they selling the six and a
halfs
okay well i know at this point there's
they're buying it so the market was
trading
um it was selling you know it was going
down a little bit it's trading six and a
quarter
then a bid came in it's trading six and
a half then all of a sudden
you know people are still selling six
and a half's now people are buying six
and a half so you know the market moves
back and forth
but the problem is when you're looking
at time and sales it moves too
fast right you can't make heads or tails
of it
now out of this data that you see in the
time and sales
you can put it into an order flow chart
like this
and you're going to get a lot of
information right you're going to get
delta you're going to get point of
control you're going to get imbalances
and you know just really quick what
these are
right every bar is going to have a delta
it's going to tell you
the delta is going to be positive or
negative or could
land on zero zero just means um
buying and selling was evenly matched
but if a delta number
my software appears on the bottom some
will put it under the bar you know
different places i just find it neater
on the bottom
you know minus three thousand and eleven
i know that in this big
red bar here there was it finished up
minus three thousand eleven negative
delta telling me
there was three thousand more sellers
than buyers in this bar
you know like this little green bar here
it's got positive delta of
536. it's telling me there was more
aggressive buyers than aggressive
sellers in this bar when it closed
by a number of 536 okay
and that's important because it's
telling you
who's in control of the market who's in
control of this bar
right and once you start putting these
different bars together
looking at delta and some of these other
things you could really get a clearer
picture of really what's happening in
the market
now the next point is point of control
not every bar has a point of control
it's the level in the bar with the most
volume it's traded on the bid
and the offer combined um
horizontally you know at a particular
price level so you see every bar has a
point of control
point of control point of control point
of control point of control
and why is this important is because you
know point of control is sort of a crude
sense of
fair price in the bar you know where
where the most transactions occurred
where you know the big traders
transacted i'm going to take this a step
further a bit later so you can
understand it
even more clearer now imbalances
some bars have imbalances some bars have
none
you'll see there's in the bar there's
red numbers
there's blue numbers there's black
numbers black numbers are just your
normal
order flow that's going through when you
see red numbers
in the volume in the bar it's telling
you you have a
an imbalance in the two-way auction so
you could see
in here right 53 traded on the bid
against two on the offer when the market
was bid at this price offered at this
price
in the two-way auction 344 versus one
all right 373 versus 44. right market's
traded in a two-way auction it's a bid
and an offer right it's bid like at one
price
and it's offered at the next higher
price okay that's why
when you're looking at imbalances you
look at it in the two-way auction
you see the blue here 58 against 303
right there's 58 sellers against 303
buyers
this is an imbalance now how do you
figure out imbalances well you could set
your
um threshold most traders use four to
one which is four hundred percent
some traders use three to one some user
traders use ten to one it really depends
on
your trading strategy how you want to
um use imbalances in the market
now like i said most traders use four to
one and you know what
that's a good starting point for most
traders i use four to one on most of my
charts
now all that information on that
footprint chart again it comes from
time and sales other people like to
think that order flow is looking
at the depth of market right the price
ladder well
the price ladder just shows you the bids
and offers and that's constantly
changing
right people are putting in offers
pulling up putting in bids pulling um
you know you really what you want to be
focusing on is what's actually trading
in the market not necessarily the
intentions of traders
now it's nice to know you know areas of
liquidity you know is there a big
offer or some place or a big bid
someplace or um
you know very little on the offer or
very little on the bid but in general
most of the time the order book is
pretty normal
okay now remember the information you
see on your bar chart
comes from what's traded in the market
you know from what you see
in the time and sales but what's the
candlestick chart lacking
it's lacking volume right volume that
traded on the bid
volume that traded on the offer that
information is very valuable to a trader
now again like i said you know the
software that existed for order flow
trading
just wasn't good enough or complete
enough for me i don't think good enough
because i was training
using it for for years but i created my
own because i wanted to take order flow
a step further than just looking at
delta point of control and imbalances
right
i know that there's other pieces of
information to be had
out of the order flow right i wanted to
see beyond
the delta the point of controls now in
this
latest version of the order flows trader
you know i can see the value area for a
bar i could see where traders are
trapped in the market i can see where
there's market exhaustion
i could see where there's point of
controls that
matter right we call them prominent
point of controls point of controls that
act as support resistance
and and so much more okay now like i
said you know the the
order flows traders got 17
pre-programmed tools inside of it to
help you
understand the order flow better rather
than just looking at delta point of
control and imbalances
right i mean a lot of the software that
comes out
they're still just showing delta point
of control and imbalances whereas you
know
traders are more advanced than that
right
and you should be asking yourself you
know as a trader what do you want to be
trading with you know
something from you know a model a ford
or you know the new ford mustang right
you want to be trading the latest model
you know that's going to give you high
performance and give you
more information that's available to you
right
now trading the market right it's just
not about watching
price movement there's different parts
of the market they're always moving
right you have to be using them looking
at price go up and down is not really
giving you a full story of what's going
on in the market
right if you're just looking at a price
you're just looking at one market
perspective right you have to integrate
other information that the market
generates
so why are you here right school you
want to learn what
traders are using now in the order flow
right you want to see how you can view
the market generated information and you
want to see how you could use this in
your trading
so trap traders everyone has heard about
trap traders right traders who are
caught offside in the market
right we've experienced it all right we
know what it's like by the dip
btfd you know it's just um you know it's
becoming part of our vernacular now by
the dip well
sometimes the dip just keeps dipping
right just keeps going down right
you're thinking oh this market's going
up i'll dip it i'm gonna buy it i'll buy
some more buy some more next thing you
know
you're you're falling off the cliff
right that's
that's not necessarily a good trading
strategy
if you're looking at the order flow on a
footprint chart
this dip here right this is the
footprint chart for that bar chart i
just showed you
you're probably not going to be buying
this dip why is because you're not
seeing
the type of buying that you want to see
right you're seeing
more aggressive selling than buying
coming in
so buying this dip you know you're gonna
be sitting uh yeah i mean i
i probably shouldn't be buying this dip
right or at least
not buying yet all right it's it's not
about
getting you know being in and out of the
market it's keeping you out of markets
you shouldn't be in
they're keeping you out of positions
that you shouldn't be in um
you know that's what trading is it's not
just you know sitting around okay boom i
want to get in
now i'm a trader no part of trading is
staying out of market conditions that
the market is telling you to stay out of
right
here's another market right this that
previous one i showed you that was euro
currency this is these are charts from
yesterday
okay all these charts are from yesterday
um there's a question there if i could
show crude oil i think i got some crude
oil charts in here
as well today because you know the big
sell-off in the crude yesterday
um late and you know order flow gave
some nice clues now this is gold
okay this market just appears to be
doing nothing all right just going
sideways
then it falls over right it falls from
1806 all the way down to you know below
okay well what are the clues right
that's where you're going to use
order flow to help you understand what's
happening
this is wheat right we you know it's a
grain
pretty boring market to a lot of traders
but
you know sometimes boring is good you
know i see a lot of traders
and it it has me shaking my head
sometimes
is people say you know what
i can't make uh heads or tails out of
this order flow
you know and i'll ask well what market
you're trading and i'll be like uh
nasdaq and i'm like well problem is
you shouldn't be trading nasdaq right
the mark is too volatile for you
especially if you're a new trader
you know i know people that are killing
it in nasdaq but they're experienced
in traders in trading they understand
the risk involved
and how to deal with it you know most
new traders
can't handle the risk involved in
trading
nasdaq so that's why i say choose look
at other markets right that's why i show
different markets here
so you know you could see you know
there's more to trading than just
trading nasdaq
spasdak as people call it because it's
all over the place
wheat is a great market it follows order
flow nicely a lot of
markets that are supply and demand
driven
right cash settled markets like
obviously the grains
bonds that have a lot of
institutional participants tend to
follow order flow a bit better
because they don't have that hot money
the retail herd money coming in like oh
my god
everyone just rushes all the retail
traders rushing to buy or rushing to
sell
you know markets that move more
methodically sometimes are
easier to trade for people but this is
wheat right it looks like it's not doing
anything
it's sort of just grinding higher you
know i know a lot of people that would
be short
and just you know still staying in the
short as this market is slowly grinding
higher
right but if you know how to read the
order flow
you know to either if you're short to
get out or if you're not in a position
you could take a nice low risk trade
here and i'm going to explain that to
you
so this was the dip right the first one
i showed you know buy the dip
you know all you know mark is starting
to sell off buy some more
selling off buy some more well
if the market is continually dropping
why are you going to be buying more
right now there's a tool that we have in
the order flows trader software that
shows you trapped traders right right
here i'll put an arrow above the bar
so again what's a trap trader someone
that's long and wrong
right someone that's short and in the
hole
right they're short thinking the
market's going lower
but the market's reversing they're short
at the bottom of the hole or
they're long and wrong you know most
people think that all trap traders have
to appear at the high of a move no
you know a market could be going off
putting in a little rally traders get
trapped
right when traders are trapped now that
doesn't mean that oh you know all these
buyers here is 39 they're seven
whatever there's 30 here these guys are
all all trapped
that's causing this move down no really
what it is it's a sign that
there's bigger forces at work in the
market because you know you're only
looking at what is this 80 contracts
right 80 contracts right here
is gone already but the market's going
down trapped traders is a sign
of um people's thought of the market
going in a direction and they're they're
wrong right the retail
aspect of the market is wrong
okay again this was the gold chart right
it looks like it's going sideways
right you see this type of chart a lot
but what you're looking for is a clue in
the market
trap traders in here okay market rallies
back
up to that area where the trap traders
were before before selling off
again this is that wheat all right it
just you know this is this red line is
the law of the day
you know it could go either way you
could just sort of grind higher or
maybe reverse and sell off but if you're
looking at the order flow in here
right i now i i know
because you know these are my tools that
i use that there's trap traders here
trap traders in this bar right and you
can see how this market pops up and
people say well it's not that big of a
move
you know it it's it's about being
consistent
right it's not capturing a 50-point move
in in the s
ps every single day you know it's about
you know successful there's a lot of
successful traders that just grind it
out you know these guys that always hit
the home runs
they're no longer in the market you know
either they blew up or
you know they had a heart attack or
something you know the guys that they
grinded out
you know ichiro suzuki the baseball
player you know is playing for
you know in in his 40s guys like mark
maguire these power guys
you know they tend to retire a bit
earlier when the drugs wear off so to
speak
but it's like having tools
that are going to help you read and
analyze the order flow is going to put
you ahead
of a lot of other traders now i used to
honestly i used to
read the order flow and see this
happening but as
i progress i'm like you know what this
is what i look at in the order flow
why not put it in software okay that
just
show me that way i could have
more opportunities so to speak i could
be looking at
more screens more charts and find these
opportunities this is bonds yesterday
look at that right off the low of the
day
nice rally up in the bonds start coming
off
boom back down to the lows of the day
right
now this is you know crude oil yesterday
right you had the nice little late
sell-off here
boom it was about a one dollar move in
the crude
okay what what's the signs
right we have trap traders here you
actually got a few more
um in here which i'll get to a bit later
with when i start talking about value
going on in the bars
but i know that there's trapped traders
going on in here okay
and if i know there's traders trapped in
here right again i'm not looking at oh
you know there's 100 traders
that were long and wrong here because
you know that's causing this move down
no you know everyone that becomes a
buyer is going to become a seller at
some point right this is what they
always say but
yeah okay maybe they're covered here
well they're out already in here
okay that's not causing this move but i
know that the sentiment has changed
right i know that
what we're seeing we're seeing some act
you know buyers that were active
in here thinking this market is going to
go back up but the market's telling them
nope
not now we're not going up now
but again you know if you're not looking
for trap traders
you won't be a trap trader right i mean
we we've all get stuck in the markets
and you know if you're not looking for
trap traders you can't see
where traders are trapped right so
you're going to be you know what's
what's the point well
you got to be asking yourself you know
is this something i can use in my
trading and
yes it is you know i know people that
built whole trading strategies just
around
trapped traders right again i'm talking
about different things here
in the order flow now i'm not saying you
have to learn every single thing there
is about order flow
no you develop a trading strategy around
one form of analysis that works for you
that you can get your head around
because if you try to apply
every single thing about order flow at
once you're going to be overwhelmed it's
like trying to drink through a fire hose
it's just too much it's overwhelming for
people
so the next thing i'll talk about is
value right most traders have heard
about
value usually through market profile or
volume profile and
you know we're always comparing price
relative to
value okay and you know the volume
profile most people are familiar with we
we know how a market
theoretically should act around a value
area high up here or
you know a point of control or value
area low in here
okay that's that's all well and good
right now
understanding where the value is for the
day is valuable information right we
we all like you know most traders will
have some sort of profile up on their
chart
but an individual bar has a sort of own
ecosystem of what's trading on that time
frame right
an individual bar whether it's five
minute or one day or a one minute a 10
second chart
it goes up and down in the bar right and
you know really what is a daily chart
well it's a collection of smaller time
frames a daily chart
can be a bunch of five minute charts put
together
or five bunch of five-minute bars put
together right just as a five-minute
chart is a collection of
one-minute charts okay like a
five-minute bar is made up of five
one-minute
bars but the same analysis that you
perform on
a daily chart you gonna perform on a
five-minute chart or even a one-minute
chart
and you're going to do that whether it's
order flow whether it's
you know technical analysis patterns you
know um
you know the head and shoulders patterns
or you know abcd
you know bats you know all sorts of
stuff right whether it's a one-minute
chart or a
10-minute chart or a 15-minute chart or
daily chart
right that's how you can tell
if a form of analysis is good is if it
can be
transferred over different chart types
in different markets right if
if you have a way of trading that only
works for one particular market
it's probably not gonna it may work in
the short term
it may have worked in the past but its
longevity
is probably going to be very short right
ideally if you're looking at trading you
want to have some
method of trading that's going to
survive in the long run
right now value right
every bar again i talked about point of
controls earlier right you know
you can see the footprints in here but
every bar is going to have a value area
now you know people say well yeah you
know you can have a volume profile
put on a bar there's a lot of different
ways you can do it different softwares
now have
different capabilities but again if you
don't know what you're looking at
it's not going to be very effective and
useful for you
and these are just bars playing bars
with no value areas right these are just
your normal order flow
footprint charts you know your point of
control your delta your imbalances
okay well that's all well and good but
you know as a trader
i want more value so to speak you know i
want the software to do
more for me so
when i had my software
developer put hey you know i want to
know the value area for a bar i want to
know
particularly the value area high is
obviously going to be the top
value area low is going to be the bottom
obviously the point of control is
going to be usually the same point of
control in the bar
because that's information for me right
because i can decide
like i can see here okay well value is
it's overlapping here right we're going
sideways obviously but value
is coming in here at you know basically
around this 05 to 10
area okay then we start trading lower we
got more overlapping volume
trade a little bit lower more
overlapping volume at this point i'm not
looking for this market to start
rallying because
i have this value area forming in here i
got another little value area forming in
here
i've got another lower value area
forming in here the bias
obviously is down now there's people are
going to want to try and buy this
you know let's say oh i got green green
green i got to buy it but
when you start looking at these bars
even these two bars here even though
this is a green candle
the value area is lower than the
previous bar
value area high is lower than the
previous value very high the value area
low
is lower than the previous value area
low okay
obviously we can't even get when we
trade back up into the value area of
just a little bit earlier
we go in we reject it we come off
so again there's absolutely no reason to
be getting long in here
instead you have a nice value area
forming in here a lower value area here
a lower value area here
value area is migrating lower the bias
is to the downside
and then boom it just dropped
you know a dollar
now here's um e-mini's yesterday right
we had this nice little rally up you
know we had a big sell-off
then we had a nice recovery but
you can see here the value areas again
you're forming a value area in here
and a slightly higher value area here
you know you have this gap in here then
another as you're going higher
and then you start adding some of the
other tools of analysis let's say yeah
at the bottom here
i got some trapped traders i got trapped
traders
so i know that value is moving higher
right in these bars you know this sort
of grouping of five bars is higher than
the previous five bars
it's giving me a clearer picture of
what's happening in the market
now every bar has a value area
okay and
that's good right but you could take it
a step further right you could do
analysis
of value areas and and what we've
realized is some value areas have
more meaning to them we call these evas
sort of expanded value areas as opposed
to the normal
value areas and if it's bullish it will
color the value area blue if it's red
it'll or if it's bearish it'll color it
red
okay and if it's just gray that's just
your normal value area nothing
too special about it i mean there are
other forms of value
area analysis but in the software we
have what we
programmed called the eva which is going
to give you a bullish signal
or a bearish signal then you start
combining it with other things
right you see the trap traders you see
um obviously the imbalances again so
you're rallying up here you're putting
in this nice rounding top start coming
off
bearish eva you got trap traders and
again there's no absolutely no reason to
be getting long here it's all
you know by the dip by the dip well
you're gonna get run over
right there's absolutely no reason to be
buying in the market boom
it just drops off the cliff and this was
the e-minis i've shown you earlier with
the trap traders
but you can see in here the expanding
value area is getting bigger and bigger
all right that's bullish and you know
you add it into i haven't even talked
about delta in here
i just talked about trap traders earlier
so you can see just
using these two tools together is going
to give you some you know nice trades
you know you get long in here in this
next bar
46 you got a eight nine point move over
the next 10 minutes
this was um gold yesterday at the low
right you got this nice eva coming in
off the low right it's covering this one
covers this
most of that and boom all the way up
from
you know 96 97 you know all the way back
above
18 bucks actually it could go higher
but this was on a bar chart can you see
value areas on the bar chart
you know everyone always says oh this is
a pin bar right it's very bullish you
know it's the best trading signal in the
world right i
grabbed this off some website last night
here you go the the textbook pin bar
textbook bullish pin bar well it failed
all right textbook examples it fails you
know the thing about
candlesticks you know i like
candlesticks i'll admit
when they work it's easy to say well
yeah that worked because you know you
had a bullish pin bar there
and oftentimes you you don't realize it
until after the market puts in a move
like this but like i say you know you
got to be trading in the present
this was that bar this was that order
flow
right here right the bullish eva you can
tell what's happening
on the order flow right you don't need
to sit here and
look at a candlestick chart and not know
that you you can know it you know this
this low is the low to buy not this low
here by the dip okay you bought here
it wasn't dipped lower right this is
where you should be buying in here the
signs are all
pointing in that bar right there on the
low the eva
again there's also bullish information
in in the delta in the next bar
and you know actually the next several
bars but you should get the idea now
back to wheat right again market just
looks like it's dead in the water doing
nothing
you know just hammering you know just
chugging along going sideways
if you have eve the value areas on okay
maybe if you understand value areas
a lot you can make heads or tails of it
but if you have a tool that's going to
highlight you say hey you know what
this one is very bullish here
you know it's worth getting long where
do you get long you get long in the next
bar where's your stop go
just below the low of this this this
value area
okay so you know you're getting long
what 62 and a half you have a stop at 61
and a half
it's a one cent stop you know it trades
all the way up to the five and a half
just over the next few minutes it's not
one that's just charging along doing
nothing and then makes a move it's
you know the best trades are the trades
that work out relatively quick
you know that's what i like order flow
that's why i prefer to
day trade and go to cash at night
especially with these volatile markets
um you know you sleep better at night
rather than
you know wondering what's going on in
the markets again this was that wheat
you know
this was that area i was just showing
you right here
okay right in here this this low is
there any reason to be buying if you're
looking at this chart people say well
you got a double bottom here well yeah
you have a nice
quintuple bottom here okay well
you know sometimes they work sometimes
they don't work but if you have
something in the order flow
you know if you're already looking at
this chart saying yeah you know what
okay we're down here at the bottom but i
got something bullish in the order flow
it's going to give you a much better
trading opportunity
than just sort of saying well i've you
know hit the bottom here
tested it again start going up and the
way most people would trade it
is i know that this bar here is bullish
in the order flow
okay but if people are trying to trade a
breakout they're going to like measure
it here
put the get long up in here or flow i
know it's bullish already i could be
getting long immediately
i don't need um to wait and wait and
wait
now nasdaq again you know the spasdac
this is mnq on a 2500 chart
2500 volume chart i was trying to figure
out you know honestly it looks the same
100 volume charge is very similar to a
30 second chart
again this is you know scrunched because
it covers so much ground
nasdaq and micro nasdaq so you can't
really
look at the numbers but the point is i'm
not talking about the numbers talking
about the value where's value what's
value doing
okay if you add value areas well you can
see value area is going higher is it
moving up going higher is moving up
as the market's moving down it's going
down valuer is migrating lower
migrating lower migrating lower
but if you take it a step further have a
tool
on your software that's going to
highlight to you
bearish value areas or bullish this case
these are bearish ones because they're
colored red
you could catch these moves as soon as
as soon as they develop you know market
went up you got a bearish
value area up in here imagine you're
getting short somewhere in here 50
55 even that's a move it's a 50 point
move
actually more because it went all you
know down to about 60.
but just this move over you know from 10
to 10 45 not even 10 minutes
that's a 50 point move in the nasdaq
right now you know it it's not always as
beautiful moves as that i mean yesterday
was an extraordinary day in the markets
in terms of the way the market movement
went but
you can see how better and easier it
becomes to trade order flow when your
software does analysis for you
like i said you know i know a lot of
people they they get order flow
charts and they start looking at this i
can't i don't understand what the hell
i'm looking at in here
but if you have tools software that's
going to highlight things to you
it becomes a lot easier right training
becomes
i'll say automatic but you understand
what to do
much better right when you add order
flow to it
it's good but take it a step further and
add order flow to it that you can
understand the analysis that you can
understand
you know we humans
tend to make things more complicated
than they really need to be you know and
it's you know my
my wife bless her i love her sometimes
she over complicates things
okay just calm down strip it down let's
take a look at something
and analyze it and not over complicate
things
right read the instructions so to speak
right and and having software that
analyzes order flows like having
instructions on how to read order flow
so the last development i want to talk
about today is order flow
sequencing right the order book right
the the depth of market shows the best
bids and offers
and it's constantly changing
but what i have found is it's better to
dissect the trades that occurred instead
of
the bids and offers that are keep
changing are you trying to trying to
look
at the bids and offers that are always
changing
is going to give you a headache are you
trying to make heads or tails and
especially nowadays the way the market's
trading
over the last several years the order
book just moves too fast you can't make
anything of it
so what i found is what we call order
flow sequencing which occurs when
a buyer buys larger amounts on the offer
at each level
or sells larger amounts on the bid as
the bids going down at each level over a
sequence of prices that's why it's
called order flow sequencing
so which do you think is more important
the time and sales or the depth of
market
well time and sales is actually what's
trading on the depth of the market
and what you see in the time and sales
is what goes into the chart right it
goes into the chart construction not the
depth of the market
the only thing in the depth of market
that goes in is
what's traded in the middle right when
bids and offers are crossed and that
shows up in time and sales
charts aren't made out of the depth of
market now
don't get me wrong there are people i
know that will watch the dump the market
the price ladder
and can make money at it they're very
good at what they do
but it's not for everybody right it's
for that select few
that can think in that way
okay and not everybody has that ability
i don't have that ability
sometimes i think i see something in in
the depth of market
i got something i could lean on you know
you watch these training videos
you know honestly i've watched the depth
of market since electronic training
started
right i used to have the actual native
terminals from the exchanges with the
depth of market
right so i understand you know i've been
i've looked at it my entire life my
entire trading career
but even i you know i you know you think
i should be a master at it but i'm not
right because people play games in the
depth of market but
once it trades and it prints that's
there it's for all eternities for
everybody to see
it's printed so order flow sequencing
occurs when the market eats through
bigger and bigger
size on the way up through the order
book when the market's moving up
now when a market's moving down it's got
to eat through bigger and bigger size
through the order book
on the way down now trying to see this
in the order flow
with the naked eye is hard you have to
train yourself to see it
but computers make it a lot easier to
see
and you can see here right this is your
footprint chart the order flows trader
footprint chart this is crude oil
i got some sequencing going on here
that's why this blue area in the bar
blue area in the bar blue area in the
bar right as the market's going up right
so you know that you know
there's good buying going on in the
market right
good buying going on in the market right
so how does that help you as a trader
is because you you know that the market
has to you know the
people are trading but really who moves
the market well it's the big traders the
traders that have
a lot of size to execute right to
get filled in the market and having a
tool that's going to help you see
where that's happening is going to put
you ahead of other traders traders are
just looking at a normal footprint chart
looking at the bids and the offers okay
fine
you know honestly that's where you know
working with traders
trying to explain to them you don't have
to
you know sometimes traders get so caught
up trying to analyze every single tick
that goes through
you don't have to you just have to
analyze
the ticks that give you something
actionable right
here right the same this is the e-minis
this is what a 30-second chart right
this is the chart with sequencing off
this is the chart with sequencing on
actionable
actionable this is bearish sequencing
this is actionable right as the market's
going down
bullish as we start going back up right
now
this is euro currency okay
so what right yeah i got bids and offers
i see buying imbalances
well if you can add a little something
extra sequencing
you can see how the market has to eat
through levels right what's going to
cause a market to go up
or what's going to cause the market to
go down is aggressive trading
aggressive trading aggressive buying
particularly is what causes markets to
move up is people lifting the offer
and if there's more and more volume on
the offer
whoops let me go back here all right
that it's got to get through it's harder
for the market to get through so if you
can get through
that chances are you could go higher
just as if a market is going to start
selling off
it's got to have aggressive sellers
selling into the bid
but if it's if the order back book is
stacked
right meaning more volume more volume
more volume and the market just chews
right through that what do you think
what do you think is happening in the
market do you think the market is
stronger
or weaker well chances are it's it's
going to be stronger because it had to
work harder
to get through a level okay
this is crude oil yesterday right crude
oil we had that nice sell-off a nice
rally and i sell off you know crude oils
crude oil is i think crude oil is going
to be having a big bull market run this
year
and you know so if you're going to be in
a bull market in crude oil i think it's
going to be a nice market to trade
because i think it's going to have a lot
of trading opportunities
and if you're looking at the order flow
right you want to take advantage of
those opportunities
so here it is right
bearish sequencing bearish sequencing
bearish sequencing
chewing through these levels chewing
through these levels chewing through
these levels
now honestly you know the first level or
two sometimes might not be much here's
eight
or six but as you subsequently get
through
more and more levels
that's important
now don't just go out and start trading
every order flow sequence that appears
you have to put it in context of the
market
right you should always be trading in
context of the market
okay sequencing on
right crude oil again on the move back
up here right
the move i just showed you here was the
move down this was at eight thirty
eight fifty start moving back up bullish
sequencing bullish sequencing bullish
sequencing if market is working to get
through
levels right that's what you want to see
if you're looking at a normal
candlestick chart you're not going to
see that right you're not going to see
sequencing you're going to see a market
selling off
right you're just going to see a market
rallying
that's why having tools that is going to
show you what's happening in the order
flow is just going to put you
so much ahead of everybody else
right by the dip by the dip buy the dip
you bought the dip next thing you know
and then what yeah i screw it i got to
get out here 60 80.
and then boom market just comes right
back up you know so buy the dip
it's all nonsense
just trade what the market is telling
you to do simple
so hopefully you can see now how
orderful just blows up a normal
candlestick chart right just
blows it away there's so much
information honestly what attracted to
me to orderful years ago is being able
to see who's in control of the market
to be in sync with the market to me that
was the most important thing is being in
sync with the market
i don't want to be caught offside i
don't want to be doing zigging when i
should be zagging
i don't be long when i should be short
right that's
orderful keeps me on those right sides i
want to know why the market stops and
reverses
so what i just showed you can be done by
looking at any footprint chart but
honestly you need to know what to look
for
and when to look for it right because
honestly when the market's moving
especially like yesterday
the market is down hard it's even easy
to overlook and miss things
let your software do the heavy lifting
for you
you know order flow is about
understanding what the traders are doing
in the market
process this information that you see
here
easily right don't make training so
difficult that you can't understand
what's happening
it's like taking all this information
you all these puzzle pieces and
you know you're trying to put it
together but if you ever try to do a
simple
puzzle you know those puzzles you know
the pictures and put a timer
you know i'm going to time myself you're
going to start to panic and that's what
happens to a lot of traders
trying to understand what's happening in
the market is it is they can't process
it and then they start breaking down
and panicking now this past hour
hopefully you agree it's been time well
spent hopefully you've learned something
that you can take and use in your
trading
now i can't cover everything in a
60-minute training session
but i've got a special offer for you so
you get everything you need to know
about order flow well not every single
thing because there's always new things
being discovered in the order flow right
i mean that's the beauty of the markets
there's always
new areas to sort of go down you know i
always use the term rabbit holes but um
you know honestly i think my training
has improved more
over the last five years by working
together with other traders
because honestly you know working in a
bank working at jp morgan or even
cargill would be commodity trading firm
you know you're taught to trade a
certain way and
um you're around really brilliant
people don't get me wrong but
you know there's a certain amount of
group think that goes on there but
working with other traders really
opened my eyes especially trying to
explain things sometimes to
to traders you know again you know years
ago i thought i knew everything about
the markets and that's when i realized i
don't know anything
or not anything but i don't really know
everything nobody knows everything about
the markets but
working with other traders on the retail
level and trying to have to explain
to them order flow helps me see order
flow in different angles right because
you know i'm trying to explain something
this way but then i just realized you
know if i just turn it
a little bit and then explain it it
makes sense to them but
as i'm turning it i'm sort of seeing a
different facet of order flow
so i got a special deal for you guys and
it's the order flows trader 3.0 software
okay and it works on ninjatrader 8. i
explained it you know ninjatrader 8
is is fine you know most people it's got
low
you know if you're going to buy ninja
trader 8 the software does work on the
free version so
say you know you don't want to buy the
paid version you're trading through
another broker you don't want to trade
through ninjatrader
you can use the free version of order
flows trader
and it comes with 17 pre-programmed
order flow tools i talked about the
value areas the
which is programmed in here i've talked
about trap traders which is programmed
in the software i talked about order
flow sequencing
but there's you know
what is that 14 other tools in there
that i even talked about today
and you can see i've gone on already for
almost an hour and a half i'm only
talking about three of the tools
showing you how that can help your
trading
now it's an easy setup just takes about
two minutes to set everything up you
don't need templates
you know that was the thing that always
killed me about the software because
i've tried
all the software out there for the most
part some of them are so difficult
to set up you just want to take your
computer and throw it out the window
that's one of the reasons why i like
ninjatrader maybe i'm a little bit used
to it by now but
order flows trader 3.0 is just very easy
to set up once you have ninjatrader set
up you just import it in there and
boom open a chart maybe you don't like
the colors of the background you change
it
fine okay it takes about one two minutes
to do all that
normally i sell it for 8.99 actually the
price is going up next month
and really what it does is it takes the
order flows trader 3.0 takes
my knowledge my 25 years of trading
at institutional levels with order flow
and puts it into a program so you can
see what
institutional traders and are doing and
thinking in the market
but i realize having order flow software
is one thing you still gotta know how to
use it right it's no point in buying
expensive softwares and not
understanding how to use it you know
we've all bought software and not
ever used it because the learning curve
is too hard but
i provide a lot of education on how to
trade with order flow
now there's a lot of people sell
overflow software out there
then they want to charge you
to teach you how to use order flow
what's up with that you know i mean
you know it's kind of pointless it's
like well you know
i want to sell you this
car but if you want to learn how to
drive it you got to pay me more money
well
you know well i'm not gonna buy a car
like that
now i give you i have a course called
the order flow trading course it's been
copied by other vendors out there
honestly
um uh it's 15 hours of video instruction
right i
it's 20 lessons normally i sell this for
297. you know a lot of these courses
that you see out there
i'm the first one that developed them a
lot of people have been copying
a lot of their stuff from me you know
okay maybe you want to try and buy it
cheaper why not just get it from the
source
now i'm going to also give you access to
my inner circle
video series a few years ago i had an
inner circle
and there's over we recorded over 56
videos
on advanced order flows tricks tips and
analysis things to look for in the order
flow
normally i sell this just the video
series the the inner circle the join was
a lot more expensive but the video
series if you want to buy it separately
is 4.97 i want to give you that also for
free today
so the software the training the video
series
together that's almost seventeen hundred
dollars at sixteen ninety three
but again it's one thing to learn from a
video we've all sit down you know i
watch videos on youtube
on how to make things or how to cook
things
but until you actually get dirty and do
the work
it's different right and trading is the
same
way um because you're always going to
have questions that come up and if
you're just watching a video you can't
ask questions so that's why every
tuesday i do a live group training
session
now here it says there's 92 it's
actually up to 107
now this i don't know why i had 92 there
but
after i do it every tuesday night 7 to 8
pm
central time where you can come in ask
questions
um you know about any market or about
something about the software
anything i'm there for you right
and you know if you don't have any
questions i just go on and start talking
about
what i saw interesting in the order flow
over the last week
okay and if you can't attend that's fine
it's
i show you how to get the replay i have
the replays all up in a spot
here for people you can see the last
episode
actually was yesterday night i haven't
uploaded it yet but this is session 109.
some people want to charge you 200 a
month for something like this
you know they're i'm not gonna get into
names but i know companies that out
there want to charge you for extra
training
wow you bought the software you should
come with it for free
so you start adding all this up together
it's already you know eighteen hundred
dollars
minimum but you're not going to pay that
it's just a one-time payment
of 7.49 again it's going to go up next
month i
guarantee you that i know that for a
fact it's going up
again i'm not trying to scare you
anything but the time to get it is now
right you just go to
orderflows.com3.html
i'm going to tell you what i'm going to
do is i'm going to put it in the chat
okay
so you can see just go to
www.orderflows.com3
and what it's going to do is
it's going to take you to the page to
buy it but this is what other people
have been saying about the software
right mike you know your order flows
trader software is remarkably helpful i
can see clearly now
what's really happening in the markets
right
you know if you here's this guy says
yeah if you really want to trade
properly and understand what on earth is
happening in the markets order flow is
the path and with mike's experience and
explanations it clicks right
so go to www.orderflows.com
off three this is what the page looks
like scroll down the page right
it's a long page there's videos there's
charts if you want to get in now
just click this button click here to buy
now
boom you click that button it takes you
to paypal paypal processes
your information i don't see that
information i just see your name
your email address and your address i
don't get any i don't want your credit
card information it's handled by
paypal it's just a one-time payment of
7.49 there's no recurring payments
anything like that in the future you
know some people want to lead you to
death you know for
200 a month 199 a month forever
right that try to cancel it you can't
cancel it you know even
close your bank account close your card
and you're still getting charged you
know
um i hate that and and i don't want that
for you either it's just a one-time
payment
right now you do have to pay data fees
and ninja trader fees
that's not through me i got nothing to
do with that those are just cost of
doing business fees
so you got several options one you can
do nothing right stay right where you
are now
basically go nowhere or two you could
take what you learned
today and try and do it on your own
there's nothing wrong with that right
trial and error for a few months then
perhaps if you're lucky you start to see
some positive results right
but you may not realize that you're
doing something wrong or there's an
easier way to do things
right or option three is you take my
hand and allow us to walk you step by
step through each process
through each step of the process and
skip the trial and error
right if you do the work again your
training takes work
it's not something we're just going to
turn the markets your computer into an
atm machine
trading does involve work right that's
why you know when people say well what
kind of results can i have well
everybody's different some people are
going to put in work some people are not
really what you want to do if you want
to put the ball in the back of the net
you got to do the work you got to work
at it right the great players
practice and practice and work at it
till they become consistent
and become successful so
you have to figure out which option is
for you
but before you do you know you got to
figure out what motivates you you know
you want freedom you know for me trading
is freedom
all right gives me the freedom to go
where i want
do what i want be around who i want
right this past summer you know my wife
says hey let's
go to mount rushmore okay fine let's go
next week okay
that's the freedom you know if i'm
working in a job a nine to fiver
it's difficult to do you got to plan you
know how many months in advance you know
tell your boss i want to take this off
and he's got to prove it all that stuff
if you're
trading for yourself and you're good at
it and you're successful
you have freedom right you have freedom
say you know what i don't want to work
next week i don't want to do anything i
want to veg out
you know this past week over valentine's
day told my wife
let's go down to the city let's just
stay in a hotel for the weekend
and just do nothing you know swim get
massages do whatever you know just be
waiting on you you know that's what you
can do you know that's what trading
trading gives you that freedom now
since you stuck around it's been a long
presentation i got a special bonus for
you it's called the order flow playbook
all right and normally i sell this for
but you can get it for free today when
you pick up
the order flows trader 3.0 right and
there's
actually about 10 setups in there 10 or
11 trade setups that you can use for
your trading
right on on finding
particular things in the order flow so
you got to get started now go to
orderflows.com
off three dot html make sure you put the
dot html at the end
okay that's the link i put the link in
the chat
now what you're going to get you're
going to get the order flows trader 3.0
which normally sells for 8.99 you get
the order flows trading
software eight order flows trading
course which is
normally 297 you get access to the inner
circle video series which is
497 you get access to live weekly group
training which is
you know i don't know if you were to put
a price on it 200
a month minimum right people ask me to
train them
and it's expensive to train them right
and
honestly this is a way i could reach
more people
live at that no
at no cost to you guys right because you
know honestly if you know
people come to my can you train me yeah
okay this is what i charge
it's it's quite expensive it's about 200
an hour
but it's you know that's one-on-one
now this is time i put aside for you and
you know everybody else that has the
software that you know anything you know
say he sent me an email i didn't respond
you know you come here you know ask me
in that weekly group training i'm there
you know honestly i get hundreds of
emails a day i tried
my best to get through all of them but
you know sometimes they go to spam for
whatever reason sometimes people send me
screenshots that are so big that it gets
filtered out and i don't get the email
but if you're in the weekly you just
come into the weekly group training
session
you can ask me a question there right
it's a time to interact with me
and you also get the order flow playbook
right which is also about two nine which
is 297 if you were to buy it
and you get all that for just a one-time
payment of 749.
so go to orderflows.com3.html
now if you want my book go to
orderflows.com
book.html again you gotta make sure you
put the dot html on everything
go to you'll get to this page you can
see here this is the link order
flows.combook.html
enter your first name your last name
click submit
that's it okay you're gonna be added to
my list and
you know whenever i do special trainings
or i got special offers um
you'll be alerted to that so go to
orderflows.com
slash off three dot html to get started
again you know you got to get
started in life you know a lot of people
just oh you know i'll put it off you
know
honestly we're coming you know it's been
a year since we've been on lockdown here
in illinois on covid and you know
i remember extra you know riding my
exercise bike thinking oh you know this
is great being on lockdown i get a lot
of stuff done
and i sort of look back now i'm like you
know what i did i got a lot of stuff
done but i didn't get everything that i
wanted to get done
so you know in life you got to get
started on things and if you put it off
put it off
the year is going to go by and you're
going to realize you're not where you
want to be
okay so i'm going to take a look at a
couple quick questions here
because i do see some questions
um does it work with
apple well it would work on a mac but
you'd probably need
the parallels software to run because
ninjatrader runs on
you know on a normal pc so you need the
parallel software
and can it be is it a one-time payment
yes it's a one-time payment
can it be used on tradestation or think
or swim no
it runs on ninjatrader but you can
execute
you could get the free version of
ninjatrader you can get quotes
for a low price you know what you do is
you open an account at ninjatrader
brokerage and
say you want to open a micro account you
put down 250 bucks then that allows you
to get the the quotes for
you know very low fees and then you just
execute through
thinkorswim or tradestation but again
it's
we we our software runs on ninjatrader
8.
um will there be a replay uh or can you
send me this webinar yeah we'll be
sending out the replay later
trap traders what indicates on your
chart that you're strapped traders
well on the trap traders what would
indicate it would be an
arrow up or down right if it's traders
long and wrong
it would be an arrow down if it was
traders
that were short and wrong short in the
hole so to speak it would be an arrow
pointing up
because that would be bullish the
numbers
at the top and bottom of bars
that is what we call the order flows
ratio that that would be another
you know i have some videos on youtube
about that and also i think on my
website orderflows.com i
explained to it what that is it
basically what it is it's an analysis
of the order flow okay
so again and then there's whole trading
strategies built around those
um what he's referring to
his you know on the footprint chart on
some bars above there'll be
a number on top and some bars below
basically what it's doing is
analyzing the order flow in the bar and
depending on
what threshold you set at it could be
bullish or bearish
does order flow work in all markets well
it's kind of a general question
because you know futures yes i mean
obviously you want to have
centralized data forex not so much
because
the data is not centralized it comes
from
many different sources so it's not going
to
sometimes what you're trading is not
where your data is coming from so it's
it's not conducive in that sense
but stocks yes um you know on
stocks that have decent volume it's
going to be more effective than on
stocks that have
very little volume right because what is
order flows analyzing the volume of
trades that goes through
what's trading on the bid what's trading
on the offer so if you have nothing
trade if it's a very thinly traded
market it's not gonna be very useful to
you
okay so anyway guys i'll end it there
for today
and
i'm going to you know any questions just
shoot me an email mike order flows.com
and again thanks for taking the time out
today so
have a great day everybody and again
thanks for your
your time that you put in today
you